Katie Holmes gushing over ten-year-old
Suri Cruise she makes every day great
and awesome the actress is making her
directorial debut with her latest drama
all we had and says her daughter
deserves all the praise in the world I
gave my daughter special thanks at the
end if she gets a special thanks for
everything every job I do cuz she makes
every day great and awesome and better
and I know myself more because of her so
she'll always get special things it was
exciting to be behind the camera and in
front of the camera was challenging but
I felt I had such a great support around
me I think that every job I do is a
passion project you're giving it your
all and you don't really know what
you're doing but you're kind of feeling
your way through it's the special
mother-daughter bond that jus Katie -
the project in the first place well what
I loved about this book is it is a
mother-daughter story they live in their
car and they really are each other's
best friends so their relationship isn't
a traditional mother-daughter and it's
more like sisters and I felt like for my
directorial debut this was a subject
matter that I felt comfortable trying
and I felt like while these characters
are unique in that they live in their
car they're really struggling the
mother-daughter theme and that unending
love that you have for your mother and
for your child is universal and you know
every mom can relate to that
check out ET online on Tuesday morning
November 1st to watch the full trailer
reveal of Katie's directorial debut all
we had
you